foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
you forget that it's a lie
in this video I will be discussing the
status of House of the Dragon because
many fans are wondering if this show has
been shut down due to the writers and
actor strike in the United States as I
have already discussed in other videos
House of the Dragon was not affected by
the writer strike in Hollywood because
the second season had already been
written unfortunately there is now an
actor strike in Hollywood as well ever
since this information was released
earlier today I've seen some very large
Game of Thrones in House of the Dragon
fan account stating that filming on the
second season of the show has been shut
down because of this new strike as of
right now that is not accurate HBO
in-house of the Dragon are still moving
full steam ahead with their second
season there's nearly a dozen new
articles addressing the issue right now
let me show you what ew had to say
because they always have great inside
sources at HBO they released a statement
only a few hours ago that says why House
of the Dragon season 2 will still film
amid the SAG after strike the actors of
the sag-after labor organization
officially voted on Thursday to strike
over Fair wages and the use of AI
technology in Hollywood however this
will not affect one of the industry's
biggest shows House of the dragon at
least as of right now House of the
dragon's second season which is
currently filming will continue to move
forward ew has learned now if you're
wondering why it's because of local
regulations in the United Kingdom where
some of the show is being shot compared
to the United States regulations The
Game of Thrones series is a contract
production with Equity the labor
organization for actors in the UK the
union released a statement on Thursday
in solidarity with its U.S cousin
stating they will support zag-aftra and
its members by all lawful means but that
doesn't necessarily mean that the likes
of House of the Dragon lead actors Emma
Darcy Matt Smith or many of the others
will be walking off the set now this is
obviously very great news because we're
already having to wait a very long time
for them to release the second season I
know I would hate to have to wait any
longer due to whatever delays they may
face I just hope all of the amazing
writers and actors are given exactly
what they deserve they should be able to
come to some kind of an agreement to
what they think is fair at the very
least unfortunately some of the other
Game of Thrones shows have been affected
by the strikes in Hollywood the other
Game of Thrones show a night of the
Seven Kingdoms of the Hedge Knight is a
different animal as it hasn't started
filming George R Martin announced back
in May that the show would shut down its
writer's room for the duration of the
writer's strike in Hollywood as of right
now there still seems to be no end in
sight for the writer's strike and no one
is exactly sure how this may have
affected the Jon Snow show when George
RR Martin first announced they were
making a series about Jon Snow he
revealed actor kit Harrington already
had his own writers for the series so as
far as we know they have already written
its first season remember they started
working on this show not long after Game
of Thrones ended it over four years ago
I'm assuming they've already wrote its
first season since they've been working
on the show for so long now the actor
strike could definitely have an effect
on that that show since they may not be
able to hire anyone to film it until
it's over while these strikes are
happening I don't expect we will hear
any major updates about any of the other
Game of Thrones show unfortunately I'm
just happy that house of the Dragon is
still moving ahead with its second
season as of right now it's still one
schedule for its original release date I
will make sure to keep you up to date on
any new information about the second
season they should be nearly done with
filming anyway so we will start to see
some new official images sooner rather
than later make sure you subscribe if
you want to know what's happening behind
the scenes during the making of the new
season also let me know what you think
about all this down below feel free to
share any insight you might have as
always I want to thank all of you for
stopping by and watching another video I
hope all of you have a great day I will
see you again very soon bye
[Music]
thank you